as far as the show you're gonna see
though you know tiptoeing through some
things with Asia that is you know the
biggest you know one of the biggest
things that I family had to deal with
this season um because it was you know
um yeah I wanted I keep though it's a
big deal
Tomica tiny harris is keeping it real
about her famous family specifically her
husband TI and his 18 year old daughter
deja after the rapper made these
comments on the ladies like us podcast
in november she alright no voices you're
right nobody will play those sports man
just check the Hyneman please give me
back my results how is their
relationship today their relationship
it's definitely much better now because
you know data is she's a very severe
right girl very smart girl and her dad's
just what's the love on her so you know
anytime he's around and he just can't
stop living on this she can't you know
it's like what am i fighting here you
know so they've been doing really good
but we haven't been able to see her
because she's been really pouring
quarantine we've seen all the kids
really put her only but once it's white
it's a very personal decision to allow
the cameras to capture a really tough
moment or conversation like that one did
TI or or deja do they have any push back
like I don't want to show this on the
show if it's a story that's going around
the world nice to me I feel like for us
it's better for us to show it and let
you hear see it hear it from us then
someone else give it to you because the
way they're gonna give they have the
least amount of information you know I'm
saying because they don't know they
wasn't here so I don't I would prefer
you to get it from us you know and
that's how we deal with it you know look
at it like this is something that is our
issue it's a
and they should know it from us and they
should know the real way and the real
reason and that's just the way we we
like it we liked what it's better that
way what steps did they have to take to
really get to the place that they're at
today and overcome those hard moments
this is a lot of conversation a lot of
you know a lot of talking a lot of back
and forth trying to you know figure out
how you know where we're the biggest
problem was and understanding you know
how she feels and you know and where he
was coming from and why he made those
things you know what he actually meant
by whatever he said there was no
malicious Ilyn intent in what he was you
know or his reason for speaking on it so
you know once you know understanding
then and you know her knowing that you
know I felt like that was a bridge to
help you know bridge to get you know
something to help bridge to get also on
the show
tiny says we'll continue seeing more
personal glimpses into her nearly 10
year long marriage to TI tim and i have
had our ups and downs but we're finally
in a great place together
it gives this time to focus on the kids
and help them grow your marriage with TI
it's something that people look at as
aspirational because you can go through
the peaks and the valleys and you can
come out on top so what are we gonna see
in terms of your relationship and maybe
the good times but also the struggles
that you guys go through yeah um I think
you know this season for us as far as
the relationship as far as I can
remember in this season everything was
really pretty good you know saying
what's probably some of our best times
and you know even when I um I found
crude it was like wow like this has been
amazing
wow you guys haven't been busted and you
know we've been like really on one
Accord and very loving and then trying
to work with each other and I said we
don't have spats here and there you know
but of course we it's been like a real
close-knit fun like like please back in
love like
time when we first got together no you
know that is you know really good
because we've been able to find
ourselves back into that to that place
and I think that's a very hard thing to
do it's like fresh new love you know be
some green beans first and then we'll
have some ice cream no I don't like that
we are such fans of eros she is the
sassiest cutest little thing on the
planet I know it was your birthday while
we were in Warren teen so I want to know
of course you pull out all the stops for
your baby girl but how did you guys
celebrate it well we we put it together
like bare last minute because I didn't
feel like gonna be able to do anything
she had one of her besties come over
which is my niece Bella and then Lele
surprised her you know the artists
lately and she spent the night with us
so um we actually had a fun time we put
like a little panie they was doing like
a sip and paint they had like apple
cider and so they was painting and she
had like three cakes at the last minute
she had three nice beautiful cake we had
a ship come over and cook and we enjoyed
it she enjoyed it brother
and we couldn't chat with tiny without
asking about the masked singer fans are
convinced the night angel is none other
than Tiny's escaped bandmate kandi
Burruss
I want to know are you watching the
masked singer we're all convinced it's
your girl kandi as the night angel right
Oh Willie why I have been watching it
and whoever the night angel is she is
jammin she is letting the people have it
okay listen you know her voice better
than anyone's do you think it sounds
like candy I mean you know disguise
I don't think you're supposed to move I
don't think she's supposed to be
sounding like candy so it could be
somebody tried to sound like candy and
changing up their voice you know I'm
saying hmm we're pretty convinced it's
your girl kandi oh yeah
yes would you ever do that show I would
do it I think it's a I I I'm just not
getting into it it's um you know this
last season but uh yeah I love the show
that I definitely will do it I think
you'd be amazing thank you
[Music]